[Musique]
bonsoir que faisiez-vous le 23 août 1989
pour ceux qui étaient nés bien sûr owen
tu excusé avez vous un souvenir précis
de cette journée pour vous mettre sur la
voie je vais vous demander de vous lever
merci données ben oui vous êtes venu
passer la soirée dans un zoo fallait
vous attendre qu'il se passe des choses
et maintenant je vais vous demander de
vous donner la main vous inquiétez pas
ça va bien se passer il n'y a pas de
pickpockets dans la salle et ça va pas
durer longtemps
tenez vous la main vous formez
maintenant une chaîne humaine vous
pouvez vous rasseoir
merci vous pouvez vous lâcher les mains
sauf si vous avez un coup de foudre à ce
moment là vous me tiendrais au courant
après le 23 août 1989 a eu lieu la plus
grande chaîne humaine pour la paix dans
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
deux millions de personnes se sont donné
la main le long des routes d'estonie de
lettonie et de lituanie
un tiers de la population de ces trois
pays s'est enchaîné le long 2 675 km
pour réclamer le retour de leur liberté
cet événement est resté assez inaperçu
dans les médias occidentaux
et pourtant il a eu des conséquences
énormes sur la chute du rideau de fer
deux ans plus tard le 20 août 1991
l'estonie est enfin libre mais elle est
à terre l'économie a été complètement
asséché parler sauf cause et les
sovkhoze et le kolkhoze parlons et le
salaire mensuel moyen est de 35 $ par
mois en 2017
l'estonie est sacrée première société
digitale au monde
le rebond est immense ce soir je vais
vous raconter pourquoi ce rebond m'a
fait faire un grand bond en avant
petit clin d'oeil à mao pourquoi c'est à
vous maintenant de faire votre propre
roman
et pourquoi la liberté qu'on croit
acquise est en train de nous faire faux
bond 2017
de mon côté je travaille sur une mission
créer un espace d'innovation et dans mes
recherches
immanquablement je tombe sur l'estonie
le sujet m'intrigue
rassurez-vous à l'époque je sais à peine
ou c'est chic c'est au nord derrière les
corons la balle à eau très loin et se
présente l'opportunité de pouvoir
participer à un voyage sur place
à l'époque tout le monde ne jure que par
la silicon valley mais comme on dit il
faut toujours aller là où personne ne va
je saute sur l'occasion et je me dis que
c'est yann et puis je me dis ça va être
pas mal
en plus je vais vivre un espèce de choc
de la modernité en allant sur place
c'était à +10 tel du monde quand même
pas rien et j'avais l'impression je
pense va être un peu comme monter dans
un vaisseau spatial en fait pas vraiment
quand on arrive à tallinn la capitale
c'est une ville médiévale fortifiée qui
est classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
sorte de joyaux de conte de fées
couverts par la 5g la distorsion
temporelle a lieu mettant l'autre sens
au coin des rues de temps en temps on y
croise des robots qui ont déjà leur
propre législation
des robots qui s'invite à la fête comme
la en juillet dernier une fête qui a
lieu tous les cinq ans et qui réunit
quarante mille choristes devant plus de
cent mille spectateurs
je sais pas si vous imaginez ce que ça
peut donner quarante mille personnes qui
chantent à l'unisson leur amour de la
nation et de la nature
est ce que la nature est absolument
primordial dans l'adn des citoyens
estoniens et d'ailleurs vous avez dû
entendre parler le week-end dernier du
world clean up des 150 pays impliqués 17
millions de personnes et le but c'est en
une journée de nettoyer le plus de
déchets possible
et bien ce mouvement a démarré en 2008
en estonie
quand cinquante mille citoyens estoniens
ont décidé de nettoyer leur pays
en cinq heures mais le véritable rebond
c'est celui de la nation une nation qui
est devenu un paradis administratif
imaginez un pays où l'état n'a pas le
droit de vous demander deux fois dans
votre vie
la même information
combien de fois vous avez rempli des
formulaires ne serait ce qu'avec votre
date de naissance vaut mieux pas savoir
ce que c'est déprimant
imaginez un pays où vous pouvez tout
faire depuis votre canapé
sauf trois choses vous marier divorcer
et acheter un bien immobilier
et encore c'est uniquement par choix et
pour le monde imaginez un pays où ces
services publics qui sont en ligne et
disponibles 24 heures sur 24 et 7 jours
sur 7
vous permettre de gagner une semaine par
an de temps libre une semaine par an
pour faire ce que vous voulez des câlins
jouer à vous vos enfants votre hobby
préféré imaginer
mais le véritable rebond de l'estonie
c'est avant tout une leçon politique
celle du choix le choix de faire table
rase le choix d'abandonner la pensée
traditionnelle verticale centralisée
autoritaire mois président excusez moi
ça m'a échappé
c'est une volonté la volonté de placer
le citoyen au centre et de le servir
comme un client de créer son adhésion
autour de services qui sont distribués
au sein d'une chaîne de confiance et
pour ça on a ce qu'il faut
parce qu'on a des ingénieurs qui vont
nous créer des solutions et nous sommes
bien avant 2008 et la bloque chaîne et
c'est pour ça qu'on dit que quelque part
c'est ça un petit clin d'oeil à owen
les estoniens ont inventé la blocs
chaîne avant la blocs chaîne ensuite
c'est une garantie
la garantie que où que vous habitiez sur
le territoire vous aurez un accès
internet et vous aurez à égalité pour
faire vos démarches administratives
il n'y a pas de zone blanche c'est la
garantie que votre identité
elle est à la fois garantie dans la vie
physique avec une pièce d'identité
mais on vous garantit aussi votre votre
identité digitale et on fait en sorte
que par la loi vos données vous
appartiennent c'est la garantie qu'on
laisse personne sur le bord de la route
on va former toute la population sommes
en 96 un an avant la naissance de wayne
pauvreté ça fait
et il ya donc un plan national pour
former toute la population
tous les âges et ce plan national
s'appelle le sceau du tigre alors là ce
avait demandé un tigre enfin il paraît
que c'est l'heure du dîner donc je suis
désolé ya pas de petits gains c'est
aussi la preuve par l'exemple se dit le
gouvernement bon très bien à expliquer à
tout le monde que tout ça c'était
formidable qu'il fallait que j'en fasse
comme ça on les a formés on leur a donné
tout ce qu'il fallait ça va leur
simplifier la vie
tout est bien mais on va commencer par
donner l'exemple sommes en 2000 ça
s'appelle i cabine est en français c'est
le conseil des ministres dématérialisée
en août 2019
le record de vitesse de prise de
décision cinquante décisions ont été
prises en 22 secondes
il y en a un qui ça plairait bien alors
y'a un petit secret ceux qui considèrent
que à partir du moment où tout le monde
est d'accord par défaut
les décisions sont entérinés à
l'ouverture du conseil des ministres
automatiquement mais c'est aussi un art
c'est l'art de transformer les obstacles
en opportunité petit pays là bas il n'a
pas de ressources naturelles un climat
un peu moyen ils sont dit mais qu'est ce
qu'on va faire un pas de ressources
naturelles
embêtant mais si on en a on a nous mais
oui notre matière grise
alors qu'est ce qu'ils font ils misent
tout sur l'éducation à 12 ans un petit
et se tenir une petite estonienne parle
couramment anglais seco des cpie che et
fait fonctionner le petit robot qui a
construit lui-même l'estonie en 2019 est
en tête des scores pisa européens et
mondiaux
autre exemple 2007 première attaque ce
vert du gouvernement
alors les estoniens vous dise c'est
normal c'est les voisins les gros
méchants et puis ils vous disent c'est
normal qu'on nous attaquent
on est le seul gouvernement en ligne on
ne peut pas attaquer quelqu'un d'autre
et puis disent bon bah de toute façon
nous a volés aucune donnée puisque faut
qu'on se mette sur le sujet on va s'y
mettre et vous allez voir 2008 ouvre à
tallinn le centre d'excellence de cyber
sécurité de l'otan 2019 l'estonie est
champion mondial de cybersécurité un
autre exemple faire des idées pour un
peu développé l'économie près de l'acte
l'attractivité de territoire ça me parle
ça
exit bas niveau commercial en général 1
trois principes c'est l'emplacement
l'emplacement l'emplacement en août ce
côté-là niveau de l'europe pas gagné le
gros lot le climat ça a fait pas rêver
les gens et ben qu'est ce qu'on va faire
là on va dire aux gens mais ne venez pas
chez nous ce n'est pas la peine est bien
ancrée li résidence une sorte de transe
nationalité numérique qui vous permet de
créer une société à distance en restant
dans votre pays d'origine tout en
bénéficiant de cette administration
performante
il y a maintenant 60 milles et résidents
et parmi ces 60 mille y résident nous
sommes six mille à avoir créé notre
entreprise depuis notre pays d'origine
alors le record c'est 18 minutes
j'ai mis un peu plus mais je peux vous
dire que pour vous donner un exemple les
statuts d'une entreprise qui correspond
à une sarl se tient sur une page a4
c'est pour vous dire à quel point c'est
sympa et quand le gouvernement tire à ce
point là l'innovation
qu'est-ce qui se passe et bien il ya des
petites pépites qui arrive
et puis un jour et une petite fille qui
arrive sur une des pépites est pas une
licorne qui allait bel celle-là elle
licorne et alors là celle-là vous la
connaissez tous parce qu'elle s'appelle
skype et là les estoniens ils se disent
la vache nous les trois pelés et deux
tondus de la latitude 59 on est capable
de créer une solution mondiale
mais là mais le monde nous appartient et
là bing bing ping retour de la fait 4
licorne 1,3 million d'habitants
on va remettre les choses à l'échelle je
vais vous donner un peu de poil à
gratter en moselle vous pourriez avoir
capitole ce que l'estonie nous montre
c'est qu'il existe une troisième voie
une voie qui place l'humain au centre et
qui garantit la liberté la liberté de
l'identité et la propriété des données
une voix qui se posent entre la
dictature du big brother à la chinoise
et la dictature solution liste des cas
femmes américain une voix qui nous
enseigne que finalement la solution
c'est pas l'argent
le premier budget national en estonie
c'était 130 millions d'euros 10 euros
par habitant c'est pas non plus la
technologie
la technologie c'est que 20% la solution
la technologie c'est un outil comme un
marteau un marteau si vous n'avez pas de
plan pas de vision savais pas quoi en
faire
ben il sert à rien il faut pas
construire une maison
et puis si vous avez des mauvaises
intentions vous pouvez aussi tuer
quelqu'un avec
mais si vous avez des marteaux un gros
marteau auckland marteau et vous mettez
des marteaux partout pour faire moderne
ça sert à rien c'est juste un outil dans
ce contexte on peut se demander si nous
notre liberté
elle est bien gardé je vais vous demande
je devais juste un exemple très rapide
les évaluations en primaire
en france elles sont sous-traités un
géant américain qui stockent ces données
à l'étranger l'année dernière
kevin il est passé cette évaluation dans
dix ans il va voir sa banque il veut
faire un prêt étudiant
il veut devenir ingénieur 35 secondes
charmante machine qui le raconte
d'après nos calculs quantiques toutes
les données que nous avons balayé dont
le fameux test il ya dix ans à 80% de
taux d'échec en probabilité n'aura pas
donc près par contre on a besoin de
coursiers donc tu peux venir pédaler et
ben kevin il a pu que ses yeux pour
pleurer
tout à l'heure je vous ai parlé chaîne
pour la liberté qui a lieu la 30 ans
mais les chaînes pour la liberté elles
sont toujours dans l'actualité
derrière moi hong kong 23 août dernier
deux cent mille personnes là le 4
septembre dernier en seine saint denis
une chaîne humaine de parents d'élèves
pour la liberté contre la dictature des
dealers du quartier
ce que l'estonie m'a enseigné ce que son
rebond m'a appris c'est que la liberté
votre liberté
notre liberté eh bien c'est la véritable
frontière du 21e siècle c'est à vous de
jouer
merci
[Applaudissements]